this is simon's institute events uh
public lecture um presented by our
science uh
science communicator in residence
um
so so uh we have this long standing
tradition of having a
science communicator in residence each
semester
at the simons institute
and the aims
doing that are supporting authors and
journalists in in the areas of computer
science and mathematics
helping them to
connect with the experts who participate
in our in our semester programs
and increasing the visibility of
theoretical computer science and also
helping educate the program participants
uh about communicating their work to a
broader audience
and this semester we're delighted to
have anil anantha swami back as our
science communicator in residence
after
a couple of years i guess
anil is an award-winning journalist
author and editor he's been deputy news
editor for new scientist magazine
he was the 2019-20 mit knight science
journalism fellow and he contributes
regularly to leading newspapers and
science oriented magazines
and he's also active in teaching science
writing around the world his popular
science books have won awards and
accolades including a nautilus book
award
and his talk today is entitled the seeds
of stories
welcome
um thank you for that introduction peter
it's lovely to be back here at simon's
um
today
i'm going to talk uh a little bit about
how
stories come about um
and i'm going to use examples from
stories that i have written
and this is by no means uh
this is this is not to say that these
stories are great this these just happen
to be stories for which i have a
backstory to tell you because i know how
they came about there are plenty of
other lovely stories out there that i
could have analyzed but i could not have
gotten into the writer's mind to tell
you how those stories came about so i'm
choosing basically the things that i
have written and my own books to kind of
give you a sense for
um
you know essentially how journalists
especially science journalists think
about uh stories or communicating
science and
well
why communicate science at all i i you
know this is
to this audience and especially
right now during the pandemic we almost
don't have to answer this question
because the effects of not communicating
science
well
uh to the audience to people everywhere
is very very obvious
but i
i kind of like this quote from timothy
ferris he says
the scientific approach to understanding
nature and our place in it has opened
limitless prospects for inquiry there is
no limit to the knowledge and power that
may for better or worse come within our
grasp yet few understand science and
many fear its awesome power and i think
this you know getting rid of this fear
particularly is really important and
the solution to this
again i want to quote uh timothy ferris
here he says the cure for fear and
loathing of science
is neither propaganda nor persuasion but
knowledge
conveyed preferably in stories that
capture and reward an audience's
attention and it's that keyword stories
here i think
we really have to as science
communicators
we have to think about communicating
these grand ideas
in science
through stories and
the stories really have an amazing power
and as
writers we have to be aware that
regardless of the complexity of the
science
regardless of how important the
scientist is the stature of the
scientists or even the significance of
the findings sometimes you're reporting
and writing about
findings that are extremely uh
important or sometimes they're not so
important in the scheme of things but
nonetheless you always have to find a
way to tell a story
you have to as a writer keep thinking
about a narrative arc whether it's a
hundred word story
whether it's a thousand word story
or a ten thousand word feature in a
magazine or even a booklet thing you're
always trying to think about stories
today i'm not really going to
unpick
what makes a story i think we all
intuitively know what that is but there
are also kind of
ways of thinking about
um what makes stories work so i won't
get into that today
so today the uh objective of the talk is
to really give you a sense for how
uh we stumble upon stories as science
journalists
uh
but
some basic things the story
you know is really not a summary of a
paper or the highlights of a conference
presentation
or the review of a field even though all
of these things go into the mix when
you're trying to tell a story
and
we all know the reason why stories work
when we hear them or when we read them
is because they have
an inherent logic and structure that
somehow stories make sense to us
and and we understand complicated uh
sort of
concepts because they come in the form
of stories
now this is different if you are
a scientist and you're communicating to
someone in your own field
you will invariably use a lot of
shorthand things terminology that you
know
between the two of you or in your group
you understand well and you can take
shortcuts this is not possible when even
when scientists are communicating to
other scientists in a different field or
definitely not possible when
we have to communicate to
an audience that is not uh savvy about
the terminology
so as writers we always have to ask
before you start writing you know what's
the story you have to kind of somehow uh
internalize that
and before you start writing about any
topic you need to be able to answer that
question to yourself and definitely to
an editor because the editor also wants
to know exactly that the answer to that
question
and
science is rich uh i mean in terms of
finding stories to tell
science is so full of stories that
everywhere and as writers
stories can seem
rather elusive at first we can't quite
tell what makes a story but once
it clicks for you as to what
uh makes a story then you start seeing
them everywhere i mean they literally
are everywhere and then
then it's a matter of you know finding
the right way the right story to talk
about for a given topic so let me just
start
by
giving you a sense of
how some of the stories that i've done
have come about
and
you know one very very common way of
telling stories in science is being able
to synthesize
a whole bunch of findings in a
particular field
that might be happening at some given
point in time like over the last five
years or so there might have been key
developments
that you somehow have to
put together to tell a story
again this sounds like a review paper
but it's not you know you're essentially
not reviewing the field you're finding
key things
um key findings that help you
tell a story that has a nice beginning
that hooks the reader makes the reader
want to read read on
you have to make the reader go on from
sentence to sentence from paragraph to
paragraph
it has a substantial middle
where you're informing engaging
entertaining the reader and then it has
a very satisfying ending how these
elements are put together
changes from story to story from writer
to writer so there's no formula for that
even though
science magazines
have formulaic ways of telling stories
each magazine has its own way
but you can also break from tradition
and
tell stories of different kinds but all
through this process you're always
thinking about what kinds of things
should go into your story that engages
the reader
and you also have to answer questions
about the relevance of the story you're
telling at some given point in time like
why now this is a this is a question
that
editors are often going to ask
so let me just take some examples of
how these some of these stories came
about
so this is a story uh
so i'm going to say something about
headlines right off the uh right in the
beginning
ignore most of the headlines uh in the
sense they always tend to say more than
what the story really is about they're
meant to be
catchy catch the reader's attention and
sometimes headlines can
as you all well know can be a little
misleading but anyway this one this one
is not off the mark
so this was a story that
was triggered in by a science paper in
2004 i was in the london office as a
staff writer for new scientists and this
paper came out about something called
tunneling uh nanotubes
nanotubules i forget whether tubes or
tubules
and
my editor came to me and said just write
a 100 word piece on it because it was
some
very strange finding about
these
channels nanotubules that
connect
animal cells so that the stuff from the
interior of one cell can go into the
interior of another cell without exiting
the cell and animal cells until then had
not known they were not known to have
this kind of communication and
so when i talked to i think it was the
graduate student i forget this was 2004.
um
either he was a phd student or a postdoc
but anyway i talked to him and and he
he talked about how
this was a completely accidental finding
in the sense that what had happened was
he was looking at these rat cells under
a microscope and he saw these
nanotubular structures connecting these
rat cells which had never been seen
before
he goes to his advisor
and the advisor says can you repeat the
experiment so the
grad student repeats it and he doesn't
see anything
and it turns out and then he realizes
that he had made a mistake in the first
the first time around apparently when
cell biologists are looking at cells uh
uh you know fixing cells and looking at
them under a microscope you have to
change the culture medium that the cells
are in between observations
and he had forgotten to do that in the
first the first time around so the next
time around when he did it redid the
experiment he did it correctly change
the culture medium and they didn't see
any of these nanotubes
so
they realized that this whatever they
saw the first time may have something to
do with the fact that the medium wasn't
changed so they went back and redid the
experiment with the mistakes and
yes lo and behold the nanotubules were
there so
this paper was just the 2004 science
paper was just about this discovery
they did a whole bunch of work to make
sure that this was not an artifact of
their measurement
but there was not much else so
when my editor wanted me to write the
story i said look there's this really
lovely backstory to how this discovery
happened we will waste that by just
writing something that is 100 words long
let's just wait
and we waited for
three years four years
then by 2008 it turned out that a lot of
other scientists biologists had gotten
into the act of you know they got
excited by this and started looking for
these nanotubes and started finding them
in all sorts of places uh nerve cells
communicating with each other so there
were lots of in vitro experiments which
found these nanotubules you know had
connections between nerve cells it was
essentially a new way for animal cells
to communicate
and they saw connections between
sort of heart muscle cells
there was also some
some studies showing that maybe hiv
uh
kind of uh
uses these nanotubular structures to
evade the human immune system so you
know previously the only way that we
knew that animal cells communicate with
each other was by sort of it was
chemical communication and there was
also there are these things called gap
junctions which allow
uh ions and molecules to go between the
interior of one cell to another but
they're very narrow they're like 0.5 to
2 nanometers across these nanotubules
were 50 to 200 nanometers across so they
they could let entire the complex
proteins get through
and the the some studies were showing
that that's how probably hiv was going
from the interior of one cell to another
in some people
who
had antibodies to hiv hiv but they could
not get rid of the virus and the
speculation was maybe hiv was you know
evading the human immune system by using
this network of nanotubules that
connects cells
so a whole bunch of such studies came up
there was also in vivo study of i think
in an in a mouse or a rat where they saw
these nanotubules in the cornea long
sort of
tubules connecting dendritic cells in
the
in the cornea so basically the story got
triggered by this one
you know serendipitous finding we waited
for four years and then we were able to
synthesize a much larger piece uh based
on all the findings that came about
um this one
was
something more recent
this is
this is why this is what i meant by
be wary of headlines deep neural
networks help to explain living brains
yeah
you all know that that's not quite true
but
but
peter mentioned that in 2019
2020 i did a fellowship i was a night
journalism fellow at mit
and as part of that fellowship i did
some courses in neuroscience and i was
attending a course
given by
dr nancy kanwisher and
during during the course she kept
talking about these computational models
of uh primate vision that had started
becoming
more and more
detailed and were really beginning to
help neuroscience so that kind of
triggered
the idea for a story of just looking at
the current state of this effort of
basically
using
uh models uh computational models
you know
built using deep neural networks to try
and understand uh how the primary visual
system works and
so again this was
this is you know it was triggered by
a few talks
that i attended where
it was becoming very clear that this was
a work that had happened in the last
four or five years and something was
really coming together so after that it
was a matter of going
um and talking to people and figuring
out what kinds of
work was really
out there and that i should report on
and learn about
mit at that time there was a jim de
carlos lab that had done some seminal
work
in 2012 2014
along with i think dan yemens was a
postdoc
with him at that point and uh daniel
emins is now in
at stanford running his own lab so you
know so the story begins with their work
and as i started reporting i realized
that there was a lot of other effort
going on there was
nancy canvasser's work
too which basically she was a skeptic in
the beginning about whether these
computational models could do
could ever be useful
but her lab has changed i mean they have
started using these to answer questions
like
why
is in the human brain
the part of the brain that recognizes
faces is distinct from the part of the
brain that recognizes objects in general
there's a fusiform face area
which is very specific to face
recognition and that was uh can wisher's
discovery in the late 90s
and but it was very hard for them to
answer the why question like why why
does this happen in the brain now it
turns out computational models can
help answer some of those why questions
and they're beginning to use
i think they use the vgg
deep neural network to try and train it
on object recognition face recognition
and trying to answer the why question
there's josh mcdermott's work also at
mit
looking at the auditory cortex and
looking at computational models of
essentially
music and
speech perception and again trying to
answer questions about
why is the architecture in the brain the
way it is that's a very hard question to
answer if you're just looking at the
brain but with computational models
they're beginning to
um
have you know
they're beginning to make some headway
into answering the why question so this
was again a synthesis
um
story and this this is going to be very
common if you look if you start looking
at the
science stories that are out there a lot
of times there are these kinds of
stories they're essentially synthesis of
a whole bunch of stuff that has happened
in a given field over
the last four years or five years and
it's put together in the form of a
narrative right
there are
lots of times as a journalist things
happen in terms of conversations with
people that trigger a story
and these are my favorite kind really
so i'll give you a couple of examples so
this is i was
interviewing stephen weinberg he passed
away a couple of months ago
um
nobel laureate in physics and he i was
interviewing him for a book i'll talk
about the book later but um
i was talking to him about essentially
particle physics and he made this
comment he said i am terrified and this
was about
what the large hadron collider might or
might not find so this was 2007 the
large hadron collider hadn't started up
yet
so he said i'm terrified discovering
just the higgs would be a real crisis
right now
it was not just weinberg thinking this
just about every particle physicist was
thinking this
but
because weinberg said it and for most uh
people who love reading about physics
you know weinberg is a known entity and
uh you know his words carry
a lot of weight so
i remember talking to my editor and
saying i think we can basically
you like this sentiment that he's
expressing is basic there's a reason
why he's saying this
and the reason is basically
that the standard model of particle
physics which
which describes all of the fundamental
particles
that we know of and the forces that act
upon them so you know fermions
and bosons
that is
seems to be incomplete it doesn't
include gravity it only the fundamental
forces it deals with are the
electromagnetic force and the strong and
weak nuclear forces
and
and and
you know
there's always been concern that it's
incomplete and part of the reason is
there's you all know that when the large
atron collider was built one of the
things it
was after was was the higgs boson the
particle that gives other elementary
particles their mass
now
in in the standard model when you try to
calculate the mass of the higgs itself
that balloons out of uh
that goes out of whack because of
i mean it's hard for me to try and wrap
my head around the technical details
there but there is something called the
hierarchy problem that really causes
the higgs mass that is calculated to be
completely out of control and you have
to fine tune the parameters of the
standard model to a precision of
something like 1 in 10 to the 34 in
order to get the
mass of the higgs within what was then
thought to be
the mass you know so it was something
like between 118 and 180 giga electron
volts so
and fine tuning
physicists hate fine tuning especially
something to the precision of 10 to the
34 1 in 10 to the 34.
so
uh
and this was called the hierarchy
problem there was another problem with
the standard model which was also
bugging people which was that
these fundamental forces
electromagnetism weak nuclear force
strong nuclear force as you go
up in energy which or rather go back in
time in the evolution of the universe
when the energy was higher
literally the first fractions of a
second after the big bang these forces
should all unify they should kind of
start having the same strength and it
was i think weinberg
glashow and abdul salaam who showed
the unification of the electromagnetic
and weak force in
into the electroweak force
and that uh that was nicely done
verified in particle accelerators but
then theoretically trying to unify
the electro weak with the strong nuclear
force wasn't working too well those
curves just wouldn't meet well enough or
satisfactorily enough
and around the same time in the 60s and
70s physicists came up with this idea of
supersymmetry which was basically
that the universe at some point
would have had
partner particles to the particles that
we know of there would have been
supersymmetric partners so fermions
which are uh
you know electrons and quarks and things
like that today would have partner
particles which are bosons and bosons
which are
the force particles that carry force in
forces they would have fermionic
partners
and before the symmetry was broken uh
when the when the energy scale of the
universe was high enough the symmetry
would exist these particles would have
been massless and as the universe
evolved and cooled
the symmetry breaks and we end up with
the particles that we have
but the supersymmetric particles partner
particles would have been really really
heavy and they would have decayed
and
at least uh in one version of the theory
they would dedicate to the lightest
stable supersymmetric particle called
the neutroleno
and it turns out that when you have uh
when you take super symmetry it solves
the hierarchy at least in in one version
of it
you know the thing that was very
attractive was that without any fine
tuning it solved the hierarchy problem
the higgs mask comes out you know nicely
it solves the unification problem of the
forces
and
uh and it turns out that the neutrino
was theoretically a very good
explanation for what dark matter might
be
so all of these things made people very
excited that okay maybe the lhc the
large hedron collider will
find
evidence of super symmetry and what
weinberg was referring to here is that
if it finds just the higgs and finds no
evidence of supersymmetry at the energy
scale that the lhc is operating in
then we're in trouble because if you
know supersymmetry might still exist the
larger drone collider has not found any
evidence of it at the energies that it's
operating in
and that means that if supersymmetry
exists now you go back to requiring fine
tuning and all of the other things that
you wanted to avoid in the first place
so it's been pushed into some real
small corner of parameter space
and
and so this whole story was
basically we got to write a very
didactic uh story about supersymmetry
which is like you know four decades old
idea five decades old normally
you wouldn't in a science magazine
revisit these things but we got to do an
explainer about supersymmetry just
pivoting on this comment by weinberg and
the why now question was answered
because the lhc was just about to start
up people were interested so we used
that as a springboard for talking about
super symmetry and so this was the story
in susie we trust susie is the
short form for super symmetry
um
something similar happened with a
conversation i was having with brian
greene about
who's a cosmologist at colombia
and uh
um you will remember him from a long
time ago when he wrote the elegant
universe which was
you know this really popular book about
string theory and when he wrote the
elegant universe
brian greene's intent was to show that
string theory would be
a theory that would allow us to explain
why this universe exists and only this
like it was supposed to be a theory that
would give us a unique
answer
to
you know why we have a universe with
these fundamental particles these
fundamental forces and these laws of
physics
and over two decades
he changed his mind right so this is
something i remember him talking you
know this was a quote from him you walk
along a number of pathways in physics
far enough and you bang into the
possibility
that we are one universe of many so what
do you do you smack yourself in the head
and say ah maybe the universe is trying
to tell me something
i have personally undergone a sort of
transformation where i'm very warm to
this possibility of there being many
universes and that we are in the one
where we can survive
why did this comment make a story
uh or why was this comment enough to
use it as a springboard for forest story
it was because it was brian green
and there would have been many
physicists thinking about this
saying pretty much the same thing
but because it was brian green because
he was
in the public eye and because he had had
a change of heart
this constituted a reason for telling
the story the story is actually
you know a recounting of all the
findings
by people like andre linde and his
theory of inflation was at stanford also
leonard suskind at stanford who came up
with this idea of the landscape of
string theory the idea that string
theory is actually a theory that tells
you about 10 to the 500 or 10 to the
thousand or even more
different types of vacuole of space-time
each
vacuum
with its own laws of physics with its
own fundamental particles and
fundamental forces etc
so
so it gave us a reason for revisiting
all of that
um
because someone of his public presence
and you know it's it's it's
it's not in this case it was not so much
the stature of the physicist as much as
how much people knew about him so as a
journalist as writers who are talking to
the public these are things you keep in
mind right so
uh this was the story
somewhere over the cosmos
uh i
i'm really fond of the
the photograph they use it's bubble wrap
basically
as a way of showing you the multiverse
um
the other fertile ground for stories uh
for journalists is to is to keep an eye
on
the debates and controversies in some
fields right and and these are usually
i'm going to talk about a couple here
they go out of date unfortunately but at
the time they are really
important to discuss and talk about and
they often times
make for good stories so this one
was about
a
topic
that was really uh sort of roiling
climate science at one point and it was
it was about something called the
methane bomb
um and there was there was this idea
that
so so methane is a very very important
greenhouse gas right i think uh
each molecule of methane is something
like 86 times more
uh effective at warming the atmosphere
compared to carbon dioxide unfortunately
you won't be able to read it i think the
it's just a
slide for showing pictures
so
and there was this concern that there is
a lot of methane that is locked in the
arctic permafrost and there was
particularly
some studies that had come out that were
suggesting that
in the east siberian arctic shelf which
was
uh which was permafro so before the
ending of the last ice age
there was this permafrost that was
basically land
and then when the ice age ended in sea
levels rose
this permafrost went under um underwater
essentially it's below the uh it's below
the sea
and in in eastern siberia so this is
undersea
um arctic shelf and this worry that as
the seas warm as the oceans form somehow
this methane that is locked up in the
permafrost is going to
be released and there were studies that
were suggesting that there was something
like
1750 gigatons of methane
that is
locked up in that particular ice shelf
and
potentially like 50 gigatons of it could
come out in one shot within a space of
five to ten years and that would be
catastrophic for
climate if that were to happen but there
was this huge controversy about
whether this can actually happen so this
story actually dug into the details of
that contours you mean so
in the end it kind of comes down on the
side of climate scientists who are
saying that that's not going to happen
there are a lot of things we need to
worry about with climate but a methane
bomb is probably not the thing that we
should be worried about
but this was again just just because
this was
uh
being talked about within climate
circles we could focus in on on it and
use it as a way of talking about big
issues in climate change but also a very
specific debate
and and nail down the details so
this is another one which was about uh
which
so i must say that
these stories have been written over the
last 15 years and i haven't kept up with
each of these
pieces that i've written so maybe these
controversies have gotten resolved maybe
they still exist so this one in
particular i'm not sure about
uh what has happened but
this is a story about
the question of whether
the
the claim that cosmologists make that
our universe is
uh made of dark energy dark matter and
normal matter
is correct so there are cosmologists so
most of you would know
that
since the late 90s our standard model of
cosmology says that our universe is
about 71 percent dark energy
the the rest of it is matter out of
which almost 85 percent is this thing
called dark matter and the dark matter
and dark energy components we really
don't know
uh what they are uh
and
the the whole sort of those numbers 71
percent you know all those percentages
depend on
the standard model making certain
assumptions and amongst this assumption
is that
that the universe is homogeneous that
it's the same everywhere it's isotropic
it's the same no matter what direction
you look in
and that it has a curvature that's flat
uh as opposed to positive curvature or
negative curvature
the curvature of space time is flat and
these
these claims are very well stood up when
you look at the cosmic microwave
background which was radiation emitted
about 380 000 years after the big bang
so those numbers are great when you're
looking at the early universe
but the the standard model of cosmology
keeps those assumptions valid throughout
the evolution of the of the universe all
the way to present times
which means that
in order
if if those assumptions are true then
there have been certain
observations of
things like supernovae in the nearby
universe which suggests that in the last
five billion years or so
the expansion rate of the universe
instead of staying staying the same from
the big bang on has
the expansion rate has expansion started
accelerating and
and much of the
that expansion the acceleration is
attributed to this thing called dark
energy
a component of the universe and turns
out if you plug it in it turns out to be
about 70 percent or so of the matter
energy content of the universe
this story is about people who have been
arguing that
we are not taking into account that the
universe is not you can't make those
assumptions about isotropy and
homogeneity
for instance the universe is very clumpy
there are there are clusters of galaxies
clusters of clusters of galaxies and
then there are large voids so when
there's over dense matter in some
regions space time has a positive
curvature when there are large voids
uh spacetime has a negative curvature
and the claim that the small group of
rebels were to say were making was that
look you have to take into the account
you have to take into account the effect
of the local
warping of space time
on the average curvature of the universe
and if you do that
then you don't need to posit the
existence of dark energy in order to
explain astronomical observations
so it was a it
seemed like a fringe idea but we could
again dig into it was a genuine
controversy amongst a select group of
cosmologists so we could dig into it and
write about it um
and i honestly don't know whether this
has gotten resolved or not
as
some of you might know i'm not sure
but uh
so yeah i mean debates controversies are
always a really
sort of important source of good stories
for for science
a single paper
it can serve as
the springboard for a whole story and
this
this one
came out i think
about a year ago
so this was a
a no-go theorem
that uh
some theorists and experimentalists had
come up with
that was essentially it's it's basically
something that
takes quantum mechanics beyond uh
the kinds of
um
kinds of things that bell's theorem and
tests of bell's theorem have achieved so
bell's bell test
let me see how much of quantum mechanics
i need to preface this with um but
basically this is a theorem that says
that in order to distinguish between
the various interpretations of
quantum mechanics the the the way
you know so then there's the mathematics
of quantum mechanics which allows you to
make incredibly accurate predictions but
probabilistic predictions of the
outcomes of experiments and
quantum mechanics is a very serious
concern at the heart of it which is
something called the measurement problem
i mean it has many concerns but the the
one of the key ones is this thing called
the measurement problem
which is the question of
essentially when a quantum system is
evolving
does the act of measurement
uh
you know
so so the quantum system that's evolving
is in a
superposition of many states
and does the act of measurement collapse
the superposition quantum superposition
into a classical state or
does
you know the active measurement just
discover
uh what's there so so for instance the
copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics will say
that
if you have an electron that's evolving
you can't really talk about the position
of the electron until you make a
measurement and it's the act of
measurement that causes the electron to
have a position
uh it's an anti-realist theory it's
denying
you know any real properties to the
electron in this case the position until
you do the measurement but it doesn't
really tell you what constitutes a
measurement like how big does the system
have to be
in order to
be considered a classical system that
can observe a quantum system so
so there are various ways in which
people can interpret the mathematics and
it's been hard empirically to shift
between them so this particular theorem
um
takes a step beyond bellstone so bell's
theorem was the first real
theorem that allowed people to
distinguish between
uh one cl one class of interpretations
called
local realistic theories and those that
are not local realism means that
locality means that
no information can travel faster than
the speed of light
realism is the idea that
systems quantum systems in particular
have properties
that exist independent of measurement
and it was something that einstein was
really fond of
but bell's theorem and bell's test of
tests of bill's theorem have shown that
local realism
actually is not a viable
picture of the nature of
reality
this particular theorem was just one
paper which basically said let's make
three assumptions about the nature of
reality let's say that
nature is local so information cannot
travel faster than the speed of light
let's say that um
experimenters have free will that they
have
the choice to make uh
to decide what measurement they want to
make
and and the third one is that
outcomes of measurements are objective
facts in the universe so if i make a
measurement on a quantum system and i
get some result that the outcome of that
measurement should hold for all
observers right seems they seem like
very reasonable assumptions and they
came up with then a very intricate
quite
involved experiment that if you do that
experiment then if that outcomes of the
experiment violates certain inequalities
then one of these three assumptions
has to be wrong
and most physicists would say
locality we can't discard that
we can't definitely give up
our freedom of choice in terms of being
able to decide what experiments to do
because otherwise everything falls apart
so the only one that really is called
into question in this particular way of
thinking is is the fact that measurement
outcomes are objective facts in the
universe and it turns out that this you
know
so this whole
story is based on that one paper which
allowed us to get
deep into
these issues about quantum mechanics
sometimes
stories take a very long time uh and
most usually they have to do with the
fact that you need to investigate
something quite thoroughly um so
and there's a lot of sustained reporting
that goes on over months and sometimes
even longer so this is a
this is a story that came out because i
was doing research for my book uh at
that time and this was my book on the
neuroscience of the human sense of self
like so when you ask the question who am
i you know how does neuroscience try to
answer that question and i was looking
at
kind of neuropsychological conditions
that disturb our sense of self in
different ways i was talking to a
neuropsychologist in zurich
about his work on out of body
experiences which are you know very very
dramatic aberrations of the sense of
self
so
and he pointed me at that time to
he said you should look at this other
condition which is also kind of a
disruption of one's self sense of self
which is this condition called
body integrity identity disorder so this
is a condition in which people who
suffer from it will say that oh this
this part of my leg doesn't feel like
mine or this arm doesn't feel like mine
um and it can be so traumatic for them
that some of them will attempt
self-amputation
and
so this professor just told me about it
put me in touch with
one of his patients and it took months
of sort of talking to people to patients
and doctors and
and neuroscientists were working in this
to to figure out
hey what the you know what what can one
write about this but also because it was
such a sensitive subject right
it took a lot of effort a lot of
investigation and so this story turned
out to be about
sort of i think nine thousand words
which is about four times the
because it was online uh
if you you know in a magazine story
mostly four pages is about 2500 words it
was like four times as long but uh
but this was the outcome of an
investigation it was like it it wasn't
at all clear in the beginning what the
story was or how you would write it you
have to be very sensitive about
the subjects because they're sharing
some very intimate details about their
lives
you know so
i won't you know it's it's online you
can look it up if you want but
so this is this is a case where you have
an idea the seed of an idea then you
just keep digging and keep digging and
eventually something happens
um
this was also something
similar not as much of an investigation
but just a deeper look at a topic in
2011
2010 there was a lot of fuss around
some emails
between climate scientists in the uk
that had been leaked and there were
allegations of
data being fudged
and everyone was very het up about it
there was also an ipcc report
about
the glaciers in the himalayas
disappearing by 2035 and turned out it
was based on a paper that hadn't been
peer reviewed so there was a lot of
concern at least within journalism and
in
in in media
about how much do we believe these
assertions from climate scientists etc
so we decided to my editor and i we
decided that let's tackle this head-on
like where are these predictions coming
from like you know so we essentially
took a deep dive into
climate models so to give to use that
sort of unease that was in the air in
2011
using that as a way to start talking
about
uh climate modeling and talking about
uncertainty being very clear about where
these uncertainties are coming from et
cetera et cetera so this this was a you
know
not the kind of story you would normally
do but because
people were concerned we were concerned
as journalists we wanted to inform our
readers about
this science
and it turns out that
you know the the story concludes by
saying
that yes there are uncertainties and you
know
predictions made by climate models but
if you're looking at sort of decadal
time scales
then natural variation is a big part of
the uncertainty if you're looking at for
the next 50 years or so then yes the
uncertainties of climate models start
playing a role in your predictions
but beyond that it's the uncertainty of
what we will do as humans in terms of
how much co2 we're putting out into the
atmosphere that starts becoming a major
driver of the uncertainty that so but it
was just a way of you know
telling a story about what's happening
in climate science
um
this is another uh
you know
source of story stories sometimes take
shape just because
you as a journalist or reporter have
gone to gone to some place
and you are there and you're reporting
uh from the site and you can tell
so
this this is a story about
this is one of my favorite headlines uh
it's about the square kilometer array
so i had gone to the western australian
outback to look at the land
there was no telescope there at the time
this is 2012.
so the square kilometer array
is going to be a radio telescope which
will have about 3 000 antennas
uh and the sum total area of those
antennas adds up to one square kilometer
and at the time
two places had been selected by the uh
astronomy community for uh citing these
this radio telescope one was in the kuru
in south africa
and the other was the western australian
outback
and so this story is really about
the land as much as anything else i got
to go there you know it was just the
story begins with me landing in a small
plane on this dusty
uh surface in western australia
and then ends with me flying out it's
just a day-long it's a story of a
day-long
trip in in that region but it's
basically also a story about the effort
to build
the square kilometer array the cosmology
that will be done with it the
astrophysics that will be done with it
etc but you're using using the narrative
of travel as a way
to get the readers interested in
in the in the topic
this this is a story that was published
in discover
uh it was extracted excerpted from my
book and i'll just mention that if we
have time at the end um
it's it's another uh story that came out
of a visit to a
to a site so i had gone to
um
southern siberia to lake baikal in in
winter
which itself was a story you know just
writing about going to siberia in the
winter
and seeing these russian physicists
working
on the ice on a frozen lake by call
building managing maintaining a neutrino
telescope so
um and this came out of a personal visit
so a lot of stories like this come up
you know if if
uh if you have as a reporter as a
journalist the
uh you know the luxury of being able to
go to these places then some wonderful
stories come out of this uh things that
you would never be able to write if you
were just sitting at your desk which is
what unfortunately a lot of us do a lot
of the time as journalists um so i
really treasure these these moments
um oh okay so i think we have time i can
talk to you about so the ice fishing for
neutrino story actually came out of the
set of travels i did for
my book the edge of physics
and
so this is the book uh cover
yeah
um
and
i'll spend a little bit of time telling
you about how the idea for this book
came about i had actually been working
on
a piece of fiction
a
novel
in which i wanted to
kind of get across
the feeling for physics i wanted to
somehow
get
readers to feel about physics the way i
felt about it when i would read about
cosmology or astroparticle physics and
things like that and i was trying to
write a piece of fiction based on that
idea
and i had written a couple of chapters i
had even convinced an editor at penguin
india
to uh
to buy into the ideas signed a contract
and unfortunately never wrote a single
word after i signed the contract i
literally just you know i froze
completely when i look back i think it
was because i just didn't understand how
to put the story together i had ideas
about it but somehow
that level of fiction was out of my
grasp but i couldn't get away from this
feeling that
i wanted to write something that
conveyed uh to the reader not just
the knowledge about the physics but
somehow brought about a feeling for the
physics and so i i was talking to the
same editor the fiction editor it had
been five years i hadn't delivered on
the novel and i was trying to explain to
him
that oh i have this other idea maybe a
non-fiction one where let me go to
mountain tops to
look at telescopes and write about
telescopes and then i will also go to
mountain tops where there are
monasteries and so i'll have one chapter
on telescopes one chapter on monasteries
and alternate them
i just i was just making things up in my
head and talking to him it was kind of
maybe
trying to make him think that instead of
delivering the novel i was actually
doing something else
he was he then he suggested oh you know
you should just focus on writing a book
about telescopes just let it be just
about telescopes just bookend it with
visits to monasteries let the prologue
and the epilogue
be about visits to monasteries but in
the middle it's just about the physics
and that's stuck in my head
i became physics news editor at new
scientist and i came to
i came back to berkeley uh
and uh 2004 christmas i met saul
perlmutter i don't know if you
know about him but i mentioned dark
energy he was one of the people who
um discovered the accelerated expansion
of the universe based on which you know
the
cosmologists think that there is dark
energy and and palmetto won
the nobel i think in 2011 or 2012 i
forget sometime around that
and
but this was 2004 he was not yet a nobel
prize winner so i could actually sit
with him in a cafe in
berkeley in starbucks and we could chat
so i i basically was asking him about
what was happening in physics so that i
could do my job as an editor really well
but then when all that was done
i told him about this idea i had about
wanting to go to mountain tops to see
telescopes and he said oh why restrict
yourself to mountain tops why don't you
think about extremes
you know go to
detectors that are in beneath the lake
you know beneath surfaces of lakes go
inside mines and things like that
that was the origin of this
book in the sense finally i came back to
london and realized that i could put
together a set of travels
that
would essentially tell the story of
what's happening in cosmology what's
happening in astroparticle physics but
use travel as a way to generate that
feeling that i was after to these
amazingly immense immensely remote
places so i went to the atacama desert
in chile to mauna kea in hawaii mauna
kea is not that remote to
to you know lake baikal in siberia
to a underground mine in northern
minnesota i ended up going all the way
to antarctica into the south pole so all
of these places where there are not just
telescopes but detectors of various
kinds right and even even to the
lhc before they closed it to
people so i could actually go in into
the tunnels and
look at the building of the large hadron
collider so uh so that was the origin of
you know this book
and uh the next one was
uh a book called the man who wasn't
there this was an investigation like i
mentioned when i was talking about body
integrity identity disorder i was
interested in writing something about
the human sense of self
and when
when the edge of physics was getting
completed
my editor
maybe just sort of curtsy just was
asking me do you have another idea for a
book
and i rambled on for 30 minutes about
wanting to write a book on the self and
told her all these things that i was
thinking of at the end of it she said
you really have no idea what you want to
write about so just go back and you know
figure out what the story is literally
that was she said you really don't know
what you're talking about
so but the desire to want to write about
the self you know it was there and
a couple of years after that
i was writing a feature uh on some
aspects of the human self for new
scientists and i was talking to a
neuroscientist in in the uk
and he
as a way to illustrate what he was
trying to
explain to me
used um
talked about this condition called
de-personalization disorder which is
also a disruption of the sense of self
he he talked about he took the
personalization disorder as an example
to illustrate something about
his work about the sense of self and
that was that was the trigger like i i
realized that oh if he can use one
condition to make sense of something he
was figuring out about how the sense of
self is constructed by the brain
then maybe
one can dig into the literature and and
see if there are other conditions that
also so we know that there are lots of
conditions that disrupt the sense of
self
um
and so the task was basically finding a
set of conditions
that each disturb the self in a
different way but also in
conditions for which there is enough
neuroscience to sort of make a case for
uh
you know understanding how the brain
might construct the sense itself in the
first place so i ended up looking at
things like quote art syndrome in which
people think and believe that they don't
exist
which is a very deep disruption of you
know the very exist very sense of
existing
i looked at alzheimer's which is also a
very profound loss of the sense of self
in its in its end stages
um biid the condition i told you where
people feel like
their body parts don't belong to them
that's a disruption of the sense of
bodily self like right now if you you
know if we are okay then
everything about our body implicitly
feels like it belongs to us we don't
even question it we don't be it's
impossible to understand
what that might feel like if suddenly
your arm didn't feel like your own right
but there are people who suffer from
that and that but then by looking at
that you start understanding how this
implicit feeling comes about right
depersonalization then i looked at
schizophrenia and the neuroscience of uh
out of body experiences that people when
they when they say that you know i have
left my body obviously no one has left
anything but nonetheless it's a very
very
um you know it's a felt experience it's
a lived experience you still have to
explain it and it turns out that there
is enough scientific work to start
explaining why it feels like that
and think and then ecstatic epilepsy or
ecstatic seizures
so
and this again this whole book came
about because i was interested in the
self i wanted to say something
couldn't figure out how to find a way
into telling the story and then that
just one chance conversation with a
neuroscientist
uh triggered the whole book and then it
took a while to put together the
proposal and then convince an editor and
then then it happened
um oh so that's the cover
and then
my
last book was on
quantum mechanics again something
similar happened i would write a lot of
stories about quantum mechanics and
oftentimes the
physicist i was speaking with would use
the double state experiment as an
example to talk about some conceptual
aspect of whatever work they were doing
and that made me feel like okay if you
know
how central like can i just use this one
experiment as a as a thread throughout
the book in all its variations from
when thomas young did his experiment in
the early 1800s with just you know
sunlight
all the way to stuff that's happening
now
um and not just the classical double
slit but sort of variations of it with
things like the marxandra interferometer
and other thing so the you know
double state experiments done with
photons with electrons with molecules
um
sort of delayed choice experiments
quantum eraser experiments delayed
choice quantum eraser experiment they go
on and on and they're all variations of
the double slit they just get more and
more complicated
and it turned out that
you could fashion a
story with a really long arc
if you just focused on that one
experiment and allowed
you you start very simply and slowly
ratchet up the difficulty of these
experiments and it's almost like the
reader doesn't even realize that by the
end of it they're looking at
very very complicated configurations
but
hopefully it all makes sense because it
has been built up very slowly it's a 200
year history of this one experiment and
using which then you can really hone in
on the central conundrum of quantum
mechanics also talk about the various
interpretations and how they deal with
um you know these issues so that was the
last
last book and again that came from
you know sort of focusing on this one
experiment and wondering about it for a
while
um
that's the cover
and
this is what i'm working on now i have
nothing much to say about this except
that i'm struggling with trying to
figure out the
mathematics of uh machine learning
um and this came about because when i
was at mit
so i used to be a software engineer a
long time ago 20 years ago in berkeley
and uh gave that up to
pursue writing
and
but off late when i've been writing
about
sort of machine learning and deep neural
networks so when i write about
neuroscience or molecular biology or
climate change
i don't have this desire to actually go
do the experiments or go do the science
that they're doing but when i write
about deep neural networks there's a
software part of me wakes up and says i
should go learn that and do that
so
and so i spent the year at mit teaching
myself a little bit of programming to be
able to build a very simple
uh
deep neural network to solve some
project i had in mind about
and so taught myself just the
programming aspect of it came back to
berkeley last year during the pandemic
and ended up taking a
online course with cornell on the
mathematics of machine learning
and uh
it was while i was learning that that
this idea for this book came about
because there was
the theorems and proofs some of them are
so beautiful
even even this the first one that uh
i learned about was the convergence
proof that the perceptron will always
converge to a solution if one exists
it was so lovely that i felt like okay
this is a story to tell people like
there is beauty in this this mathematics
how do i convert all of this mathematics
into a narrative
i have managed to convince my editor to
let me put equations into the book i
have no idea how it's going to work out
uh
i have no idea whether it'll sell even
one copy
because you know that famous thing that
stephen hawking said that you know you
put one equation in the book and it
halves the sales of the book
and he managed to convince his editor to
allow him to put equal to mc square
uh
and mine has basically if i follow that
curve of half for every equation this is
going to be zero sales basic
so
anyway and this is the next book and uh
hopefully in a couple of years this
should be done so
yeah thank you very much
and uh
fascinating i was curious like for you
um what is
i mean i find myself envious of you you
know listening to your talk like that
you get to explore all these different
areas of science i was curious like for
you what is the most satisfying part of
your job is it is it being able to
satisfy your curiosity about all these
stories or is it the you know ability to
communicate this to people like what
what is you know the
essence i think it started for me
it's both i love writing
so the act of writing is
joyful
uh so the the communication part or even
just you know i almost when you're
writing you almost forget that there's a
reader you're just writing because you
like that
that aspect of it but i also love the
science part of it so it took me a while
when i was doing like i said i was doing
software here in berkeley
i loved science reading about science
and i loved writing and i i used to
write fiction
on my own and
i i never put the two and two together
even though the things that i was
reading
like popular science books were written
by other writers it never occurred to me
that i could combine the two so the day
that occurred to me that oh i could
actually write about science
that was
a light bulb going off for me
um
and uh so it's both so i i love the so
i'm a you know as you as you can tell
i haven't specialized in any particular
field
um so i
i happily write about molecular biology
or quantum mechanics or machine learning
you know anything goes
um
and
that's
both good and bad i mean you you know
like i said there are stories that i
talked to you about today that were
written 10 years ago 15 years ago
that i haven't followed up on
because i haven't kept up with that
particular aspect of the science
so
yeah i mean
short answer both
communicating and the science part
just just as a counterpoint to what
we're talking about i
wonder how you'd react to that so one of
the finest pieces of popular science
writing i've read is the iron man's qed
there's not a story there
so how would you you know can you can
you compare and contrast and say where
where do
you know what that says about so
yeah so so
i mean there is a story there
story of a
a discovery right i mean qed is his own
it's an it's a journey of it's an
intellectual journey right i remember
reading that and thinking
why didn't my professors teach me
physics like this right like when you
learn about
reflection and refraction
the way he talks about it
um
so
but you're right it's different and
there are books written by people like
him
um you know uh
richard dawkins stephen hawking carl
sagan etc you know so they are what you
would call in the parliament science
writers they're essentially writing
communicating their
their perspective their opinions their
work
it's rarely reported like feynman is
writing about what
his work is about or
you know uh
about around his work so but when when
what i am talking about
as journalists we don't have that depth
of knowledge about any one field
so we have we come at it differently but
i agree with you i mean that works as a
that's why i didn't try to unpick what a
story is there's no one definition they
lit there literally are
as many stories as there are writers and
as long as you can
engage the reader from the word go
you're appealing to like in in the book
on machine learning that i'm going to
write i'm really going to depend on the
reader's interest in wanting to know
about this
it's going to be very hard
to
kind of pull the reader along paragraph
to paragraph if they don't want to learn
the math right and so i think qed works
at that level where you are reliant on
the reader's curiosity as much as
anything else
whereas the other kinds of things that
i'm talking about is where you're using
your writing to keep the reader hooked
and never letting the reader go
so books like qed would be very hard for
someone like me to write
but it works i would agree it's an it's
a story of an intellectual journey
right
actually there was one other example of
that um
it's it's a video i've watched a few
times um
and um you know of course i was i was
incredibly impressed with it
then a few years later i went back and
watched it and
you know i was even more impressed so
this was uh
this was the the double slit experiment
you know finance lecture on that
yeah
so so um
the
my book uh
first chapter
is literally about that lecture
you know five minutes lecture at cornell
when he walks it's the sixth lecture in
that series
and he walks in
by then the students are so used to him
he doesn't even say hello like he just
starts off
like i mean it's just amazing it's a
fabulous lecture
he's telling a story there
he builds he's basically creating a
curiosity
he's making sure that you are now
interested in wanting to know the answer
and then tries to answer it
but it's a it's a masterpiece and so i
essentially use that lecture as a way to
set up that book because that was the
beginning of the interest in the double
state experiment in the way feynman had
envisioned it
oh sorry
well okay
maybe it's a flip side question to the
presentation is there some
scientific understanding why stories
have such a great effect
why why
we even dreaming stories guys that they
obviously play a very important role
what
is there some science
a neuroscience understanding
i won't be able to tell you what the
neuroscience the people are look have
looked into it i i think there are there
have even been articles about that
i have started understanding this like
so this became very clear to me when i
wrote the book on the sense of self
right one of the things that unravels
in
alzheimer's for instance
is this thing called the narrative self
so there are cognitive processes in us
that
create stories about ourselves
so like if i ask you who are you
you're going to tell me a story
you know it will feel yeah that's uh
well if you're if let's say you're not
intending to deceive
you're just going to tell some story
that feels correct to you but it's a
consistent story in your head
and
and that story will change depending on
your circumstance but there is an
internal consistency that the cognitive
processes have
so there's something about
it's almost like
those processes are creating a story
to for us to be what we are
and that's the part
that comes apart in alzheimer's
so if you talk to someone
with mid-stage alzheimer's where some of
these processes are intact but memory is
getting disrupted in certain
ways they will when they're talking to
you you will
they will come across as if they're
completely convinced of the story that
they're telling you if you didn't know
their life history you would be
convinced too
but if you did know their life history
then you realize that they're completely
mixing up episodes the
the the way the timeline is organized is
wrong
uh so some consistency is going away
so
if if so it seems like there's an
internal consistency to stories that we
already have because that's what we are
as human beings
and
maybe when stories make sense to us we
are co-opting some of that same
cognitive machinery to say oh that that
makes sense
i'm just speculating
sorry
all right first of all i want to thank
you for your talking
thank you
you were talking before that you studied
the uh
it's laughably simple for an audience
like this uh you know to talk about a
machine learning project at simon's
institute
but i'll tell you i was essentially
interested in right you know it was
essentially a tool to learn
uh about deep learning so the project i
had in mind was
if i had data about planetary basically
recreate what kepler did
when he came up with his three laws of
planetary motion so i was trying to
figure out
given
arbitrary positions of mars
for the last 10 years can i make
predictions about where mars will be
five years from now
uh
you know it turns out it's a very simple
problem for me it was a giant thing at
that time so but it really was it was a
way of getting back to learning python
and pytorch and
the mechanics of it were more difficult
than the
thank you problem
[Music]